early this january when our school told
my unboxed boys to stay home because of
a cove at close contact while vaxxed
kids could continue to attend i decided
to pull them out
i've been homeschooling since then what
do you predict for the fall
home study has been incredible but my
nine-year-old misses his friends
uh
right i think there's two questions in
terms of what to predict for the fall
there's what actually happens with kovid
and i would expect
bad stuff to return
and then there's what the political
structure wishes to do with that it may
wish to ignore it in which case it might
be that
this disappears into the noise of other
winter illnesses
or it could be that it wishes to utilize
it in which case it could be
more
tyranny and it's very hard to predict
because we don't know what it's trying
to accomplish and whether or not it's
decided to switch topics and use
something else as an excuse for tyranny
um
but
uh i
i i have serious concerns about about
what takes place uh in the fall and uh i
would not
i would not count on the fact that
the worst is behind us it may be or it
may be that the topic switches and
you know
what we are normally driving each other
crazy over is
about something different but the effect
is the same
yeah with regard to the particular
benefits of school versus home school
i think especially given what
many of the things that we know to be
going on in many schools at this point
if you are the kind of person who can
write this question you are almost
certainly going to deliver a better
education to your to your uh
daughter son i don't remember
um
but uh exactly as you say it's the it's
the social part of it that's so valuable
that you can't replicate right children
children should have others
um you know it's also totally artificial
that we put them all in a room with only
their same age that's very artificial
but children should be with other
children and learning from them and not
just learning from their mother or their
father or
you know a few adults and so that that
is
um the extraordinary benefit of school
that of course all that zoom schooling
pretended didn't exist um which was
ridiculous
uh and
that is the
the very big loss
uh that um
the children being homeschooled alone
rather than in say a community a small
community of of parents who are
homeschooling
i think that's probably the biggest
negative uh and there and there aren't
that many
yeah
i wonder i mean i think partially the
problem is that those of us
who
did not
um
those of us parents who did not buy the
party line
sufficient that we found ourselves at
odds with
their schools
are sufficiently outnumbered
that
the obvious thing doesn't happen i mean
i i don't know why we're sending our
kids to school in the first place it's
like we send them to a place where they
are actively being miseducated
what exactly is our rationale for doing
this okay it's because they need the
social stuff but on the other hand
what is the social stuff well they are
learning to sit masked with other people
who don't call out obvious [ __ ]
and
you know at what point do you say
well i don't know which tragedy of
history we're living in but it's
obviously one of them and
one's first obligation in such a thing
is to protect their children and protect
them from what well i don't know what
all they need to be protected from but i
do know that that's part of it and maybe
they should be gathering
you know all of the all of the people
whose parents recognize that school is
now an actively negative
anti-educational
place that instills conformity and fear
all of those people should probably be
gathering their children and making some
effort at
uh formally educating them but largely
just giving them
normal social
inputs and
insulation from
mental garbage
right that would be cool so i don't
understand why there's not a widespread
outbreak of this i don't understand why
we're all on autopilot with respect to
um yes it's terrible that post-modernism
has taken over college but i'm still
sending my kid there like okay i
understand that we don't know what we're
supposed to do instead
but
again we are all of us including us are
actively sending our children to places
that we know are hurting them and i
i'm amazed that we
haven't opted for absolutely anything as
an alternative to that right it's that's
awesome we do have at least a uh
at least a temporary alternative for for
one of our boys coming up yep yep and
maybe it's
maybe that or something like it becomes
the replacement for in that case college
[Music]
you